there were seven saw movies from 2004 to  2010 and we haven't seen a new movie  sense but it looks like an eighth saw  movie could be in the works considering  how successful the franchise is it's not  too hard to believe according to  tracking board Josh Stolberg and Pete  Goldfinger the duo who wrote piranha 3d  have been hired to write the sequel saw  legacy as it's currently called will  also bring back creators james wan and  leeuwen l as executive producers there's  currently no word on whether tobin bell  jigsaw himself will also return tracking  boards story is just a report so we'll  have to wait for official word from  lionsgate but we may just get more  reverse bear traps in the future keep  your eye on gamespot for more  you